[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER:
All right, so we're
going to talk about number.
I got a little carried away with
the behavioral work on number
because I just think
it is so awesome.
And I think it's, frankly,
a little more interesting
than a lot of the neural work.
So this is going to be sort of
a behaviorally heavy lecture.
But let's start by thinking
about why we have number
and what we use it for.
And the first
thing to realize is
that we use concepts of number
and quantity like all the time.
Most obviously, if you're,
say, getting change at a store.
I guess that doesn't really
happen very much anymore.
People are going to forget how
to subtract because they just
put their credit card
or bump their phone
or whatever they do.
But anyway, it used
to be that you handed
over this stuff called money
and that coins came back
and that was the
subtraction involved.
We use it to tell time
or to fail to tell time,
as in my case this morning.
To choose the larger
of two objects,
that's a continuous
idea of quantity,
not a discrete idea of number.
To choose the shortest line
at a grocery store, right,
and all of those kinds of
things are comparing quantities.
And we also take these basic
ideas of number and quantity
and we build on them
in modern societies
to do all kinds of amazing
things like engineering.
Like all of modern science
is highly quantitative,
like all of computer science.
And so these are really
fundamental ideas.
And animals, it turns out,
are capable of mastering
very simple but sophisticated
understandings of number
and even arithmetic
computations.
They can learn about order
and number and quantity.
OK, and they need to
for lots of reasons.
So here, just a brief overview
of some of the situations
where animals need concepts
of number and quantity
in the wild.
Foraging, right, so
animals spend a lot of time
rooting around for
food over here,
food over there,
deciding when to keep rooting
around here despite diminishing
returns and go somewhere else
where there's unknown pay off,
unknown amounts of food.
So that's a whole math
of foraging behavior.
OK, so that deals with
the rate of return
of the food at each location
and the amount and the quality.
And you can imagine a whole math
to optimize the amount of food.
They also need to know
about number and quantity
when they form teams, which
many animals across taxa
do in different ways.
So schooling fish
can quickly pick out
the more numerous
school of fish to join.
And that's what they want to
do because your statistics are
better if they're a
predator if you're
in the larger school than
the smaller school, right?
So your chance of getting
eaten is reduced just
dividing by the
number of options.
And then there's
all kinds of animals
that take into account the size
of groups of their own species
or other species when making
decisions about how far to run
or who to chase or
who to predate on
or who's at risk of
predating upon you.
So lions hunt in teams.
And they have to work together.
They have actually whole
strategic situation
where different lions play
different parts like a football
game.
And they have to decide
which groups of predators
to take on based on
numerical advantage.
And my favorite is the n
plus one frog, the Tungara
frog that lives in the
rainforest in Puerto Rico.
And it literally one ups
other frogs, the males
do in trying to
impress the females.
And so what happens is that one
frog will start calling out.
One male frog will
start calling out trying
to sound all hot to the gals.
And then another frog will
one up him by doing that call
but elaborating on it
by adding an extra call
or an extra component.
So for example--
[FROG CALL] OK, so that's
one dude calling out.
And not to be outdone,
the next guy calls back.
[FROG CALL] And apparently,
if you follow these guys, they
pretty systematically add one
to the previous frog's call,
right, up to a point.
The point being
approximately four.
So it's not like 100 and 101.
But it happens.
OK, so that's just a broad
overview of some of the cases
that understandings
of number and quantity
arise in natural environments
without training.
So we want to know how is
all this computed in the mind
and brain.
And so what are the foremost
thinkers on this topic
is Stan Dehaene, shown here.
And he wrote in a very
widely cited book, actually
review article and book quite
a while ago, 20 years ago,
he said, animals, young
infants, and adult humans
possess a biologically
determined,
domain-specific
representation of number.
So this is a very kind of
extreme, hardcore claim.
We will see at the
end of the lecture
that he has backed
off that claim.
OK, so a couple of things,
biologically determined,
he's kind of implying
innate, right?
Domain-specific, I've
avoided this phrase,
for the most part, because
it's kind of like jargon
gobbledygook.
But it's actually so
entrenched in our field
that it's worth
knowing what it is.
Domain-specific is just this
idea of functional specificity
that I've been talking about.
But you can apply it to not
just a piece of brain like,
does this patch of brain
process only faces?
You can also apply it
to a mental process
even if you don't know what
its actual brain basis is.
So do we have special
mental machinery
for thinking about
numbers that's
distinct from our machinery for
face recognition or navigation
or language or whatever else?
OK, so that's what
domain-specific means.
And it's worth
knowing because you'll
encounter it in other contexts.
OK, so in more
detail, Stan says,
a specific neural
substrate, located
in the left
intraparietal area, is
associated with knowledge of
numbers and their relations,
which he defines
as number sense.
The number domain
is a prime example
where strong evidence points
to an evolutionary endowment
of abstract, domain-specific
knowledge in the brain
because there are parallels
between number processing
in animals and humans.
Again, kind of hardcore claims.
Not just is there this so
he doesn't quite say innate,
but he's strongly
implying innate.
I mean, that's evolutionary
endowment, that
basically means innate, right?
It's an evolved ability that
lives in a particular part
of the brain.
OK?
So who would a thunk, right?
Number, right?
You think of number as something
you get taught in school.
But no, he's saying
it's really part
of your biological endowment.
It has a particular
brain region.
And all of that may be if
not completely independent,
it may exist without
explicit training.
OK?
So that's quite a claim.
So what does number
sense mean exactly?
Well, what Stan and others in
the field mean by number sense,
it's a bunch of things.
First of all, the idea
that for human adults
to have number sense, that
means they can represent
large numerical magnitudes
without verbal counting, right?
So counting is an
interesting thing.
But we're going to leave
it aside for the moment.
Number sense is a
more general idea
that's going to apply
to animals and infants
without explicit counting.
OK, so you can have some way
of representing that there's
a lot of things here.
And there's fewer things there.
Second of all, these
representations
are approximate.
And the ability to
discriminate two of them
depends on the
ratio of those two,
not the absolute difference.
OK, and I'll show you in more
detail what I mean by that.
It's a deep fact
about number sense
and actually all of
perception, pretty much.
Further, the idea is that these
representations are abstract.
They're not just, say, a
particular visual form.
Like approximately
13 looks like this.
No.
They're going to generalize
across modality, OK,
and space and time.
Next, these mental
representations of number
can be used in operations.
Even without counting and
being explicitly informed,
you can add approximate numbers.
You may be thinking, what
the hell am I talking about?
But I'll show you in a second.
So for example, I'm going to
show you two sets of dots next.
And you're just going
to shout out first
if the first set
of dots had more,
if there were more
dots in the first array
and second if the second
array had more dots.
OK, ready?
Here we go.
Boom.
Second.
Duh.
OK, let's try another one.
And another one.
Uh huh.
Another one.
I noticed the volume decreasing.
And I noticed some hesitancy.
Actually, I'm not
sure about that one.
OK, so how did you do that?
What did you do?
Did you go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5?
No.
I tried to do it, so there
wasn't time to do that.
How'd you do it?
AUDIENCE: I kind of tried
to see like the density,
like how close
all the dots were.
NANCY KANWISHER: Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
And did that work for you?
Did that work OK?
AUDIENCE: It seems to be OK.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
what Jack is pointing to
is a really important
thing in thinking
about number, which
is that number
is confounded with area extent.
How much total yellow
stuff is on the screen?
And it's confounded
with density.
And this is a big
problem in people who
want to do research on number.
And so what they usually
do is you can't totally
unconfound those things.
But you can unconfound
them one at a time.
So you can vary the
size of the objects.
And you can vary the
density across trials.
So no one of those cues will
enable you to do it fully.
This example isn't great
that way because they
were all the same size, right?
OK, but so the point is,
without explicitly counting,
and God knows what you
do it, how you do it,
you just feel like you have
a sense of roughly how many.
Everybody got that sense?
OK, so that's what we
mean by number sense
is that sense that you
can just look at something
and have a sense of
roughly how many.
Like you don't know
if it's 19 or 18,
but you know it's not 13, right?
OK, right.
Oh, and you guys all got
quieter when the numbers
got closer together.
OK?
It gets harder when the
numbers are closer together.
OK, so in experiments that have
quantified this, lots of people
have looked at this.
Here's one that I was
involved in way back.
Just like you did,
this is the task here
that you guys just did.
And here are some
of the data we got.
So let me walk you through this.
This is accuracy on a bunch
of different comparisons.
16 dots versus 32 dots, people
are pretty much 100% correct.
OK?
This is just normal
human adults.
16 versus 24, great.
16 versus 20, pretty good.
16 versus 18, now
we're really dropping.
16 versus 17, forget it.
Can't do it.
OK?
So performance falls off as the
numbers get closer together.
OK?
So that's sort of intuitive.
But now let's consider these
are all comparing to 16.
Here, we compare to eight.
Eight versus 16.
Eight versus 12.
Eight versus 10.
Eight versus nine.
You see the same fall off as
the numbers get closer together.
OK?
So far, so good.
But now we can ask, what
determines that fall off?
Is it the absolute
difference or the ratio?
And the way we tell is we plot
the ratio of those two curves,
and we look at performance.
And we see they are spot
on top of each other.
That tells us that it is not
the absolute difference that
determines your
ability to do this
but the ratio of
the numbers of dots.
OK?
It's sort of intuitive, right?
But it's amazing how
clear the result is.
Everybody get that?
OK, so this is a really
deep fundamental fact
about perceiving
approximate number.
And it's actually,
more generally,
a fact about perception.
It's called Weber's law.
And it just means that
the discriminability
of, in this case, two
numbers, two numerosities,
depends on their ratio, not
their absolute difference.
The exact same thing holds for
evaluating which of two stimuli
is brighter, which of
two objects is heavier,
which of two sounds is louder.
They all follow.
The ability to do
that is a function
of the ratio of the, two
not the absolute difference.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
with the size of the dots?
NANCY KANWISHER: So
in this experiment,
we varied the sizes every
which way and the density.
As I mentioned before,
you can't completely
unconfound both size and
density within each trial.
But across trials,
you can muck them up.
So you can ask whether
people are doing it
by size or by density.
OK?
And we did all that here.
OK, so this is not shocking yet.
It's just kind of a basic,
deep, clear fact about whatever
our mental
representation of number
is, that it's this
approximate thing.
It's pretty good.
And its precision scales
with the magnitude.
OK, all right, so this has been
quantified in lots and lots
of experiments.
And this is called
the Approximate Number
System, or ANS.
And the standard test that's
been used in lots of studies
to measure people's
kind of number acuity
is a lot like what
I just showed you.
You show an array like this.
And you say, are there more
yellow dots or blue dots?
And people very quickly
say yellow, in this case.
And then you ask for
a case like this.
And they're a little
slower, right?
And here, you can see that
the sizes have changed
and have been orthogonalized.
OK, so the ratio of
yellow to blue dots
is called the Weber
fraction, right?
This is this idea of Weber's law
that determines your accuracy
from just that ratio.
And so you can measure people's
Weber fraction, their ability
to do this task, their
kind of number precision.
And what you find
is, first of all,
that there's very big
individual differences.
OK?
Now, this is interesting.
It's like things that we've
seen in other domains.
There are very big
individual differences
in navigational ability.
There are very big
individual differences
in face recognition ability.
And in both of
those cases as well,
there are people who are just
so bad at it, from an early age,
that it's like a syndrome.
In this case, it's called
developmental dyscalculia.
I think I didn't fit it into
the navigation lectures.
But there's a whole kind
of developmental disability
in navigation that's called
developmental topographic
agnosia.
People were just always
really awful at knowing
where they are, right?
And I did mention
developmental prosopagnosia.
People were just always
awful at face recognition.
In each of these cases,
in the apparent lack
of any evidence of brain
damage and in the absence
of differences in IQ
or other abilities.
So it seems like each
of those abilities
has a very broad range.
At the bottom end
of the range, it's
really kind of affects
your life you're so bad.
And it's unrelated
to other abilities.
And I think that's
pretty interesting
because it goes
along with the idea
that those mental abilities are
really distinct parts of mind
and brain.
You can have a
crappy number sense,
and it doesn't mean that
you're bad at other things.
You just have a
crappy number sense.
It's a separate system, right?
OK.
Approximate number
sense develops slowly.
It's best at age 30.
You guys are still
on the upswing.
We won't talk about me.
This is what do we have here?
This is Weber fraction.
So the Weber fraction
is what that ratio
needs to be for you to be fairly
accurate on whatever criteria
they chose.
And so a small fraction
means you're better.
And so it goes down.
And this is age
here, best at 30.
And this is reaction time,
which goes up for everything.
What a bummer.
Anyway.
Interestingly, early ability
with approximate number
on this kind of a test
predicts later math ability
with very different
kinds of organized math
that you learn in school.
So here's a study
that looked at that.
They asked whether this
early approximate number
sense is predictive of
later arithmetic ability.
And so in this case, they
did a task like this.
And their measure, they didn't
use the task I just showed you.
This is another thing you
can do with little kids.
You just flash this up.
And you just ask them,
how many dots are there?
And they have to
say four, right?
And you just measure
reaction time.
It's pretty basic.
OK?
And so then what you do is you
run this on kindergarteners.
And you define groups
that are slow, medium,
or fast at this task.
OK?
So then you follow them.
And you look at them
later, in this case,
at age nine and six years.
And what you see is, even
these older kids, who
are defined by the slow, medium,
or fast group in kindergarten,
this is now their accuracy
at arithmetic tasks
four years later.
Yeah?
So it's not just some
weird little task
that psychophysicists made
up to measure God knows what.
It's predictive of your
later arithmetic ability.
OK?
So it matters.
So the speed of this dot
estimation task at kindergarten
is not associated with later
abilities of other kinds,
like Raven matrices, which is
one of the standard measures
in an IQ test, right?
It's a nonverbal and
non-number kind of task.
Or ability to name digits
or letters or other things
that you can test
kids on in however old
they are, nine years.
OK?
So it's specifically predictive
of later arithmetic ability.
Everybody with me?
So it matters.
All right, and that suggests
that there would be ways
to intervene in dyscalculia.
Potentially, you could
catch the kids early
who are destined
to have a hard time
and maybe figure out what
you could do about it.
And there are efforts
underway to do that.
OK?
OK.
OK, so I'm going to show you.
We're exploring these
various number abilities.
I'm going to show you
something interesting
about symbolic numbers.
So far, we've been telling
you about nonsymbolic numbers.
That means just dot arrays.
Now we're going to deal
with symbolic numbers.
I'm going to flash up
a bunch of numbers.
And you're just going to say
bigger if it's bigger than 65
or smaller if it's
smaller than 65.
Really easy.
But you're going to shout
it out loud and clear.
Ready?
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: Smaller.
NANCY KANWISHER: Good.
AUDIENCE: Bigger.
AUDIENCE: Smaller.
Bigger.
Smaller.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, did you
guys see what happened there?
Did you feel what happened?
When the numbers get closer
to 65, you're slower.
Now you think about it, why
the hell is that, right?
If you run this in
Matlab, it's not
going to take longer to tell
you that 63 is smaller than 65
than it takes to tell you
that eight is smaller than 65,
right?
I assume.
I haven't tried it.
But I doubt it.
So what does that mean?
That means that even
when you are dealing
with symbolic numbers,
numbers that you
have this whole elaborate
edifice you've been trained
on how to operate with these
guys, especially you guys,
you are still invoking
some kind of notion
of the continuous quantity.
You haven't totally
left that idea behind
and moved off into
some abstract space.
You're still, even in doing
this very literal, exact
symbolic number task,
you find it easier
when the numbers are farther
apart than when they're closer.
Yeah, Talia?
AUDIENCE: Could it be because
of the number you chose?
So if you chose the
numbers 60, let's say,
I feel like we
read left to right.
And they maybe
have a good concept
for the number of
digits that we see.
So when we see a
number like 62, we
have to read both the digits
instead of just the one.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, but all the ones
I showed were at
least two digits.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But when you read, like when
you see a number like 25,
you see the two.
And then you automatically
like know that.
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, fair enough.
OK, that's a good
counter explanation.
But you guys were
slow even with 58.
I think, right?
We could test that.
I'm pretty sure all this has
been tested pretty carefully.
I don't know this literature
totally thoroughly.
But I doubt-- it's a
good alternative account.
And there might be some effect.
But I think it's--
oh, in fact, in fact,
actually, there is, yeah,
I have data coming up next.
But right.
Blah, blah.
OK, here's the data.
OK?
It's pretty continuous.
So I think your good, plausible
alternative doesn't seem
to capture very much of it.
OK?
So yeah, this is what
you guys just did.
And does everybody get how this
kind of reveals that even when
you think you're doing
this kind of more
symbolic abstract
thing, you're still
tapping into some kind
of continuous notion?
Yeah?
OK.
So that says not only
does your ability
to do that in kindergarten
predict your ability
to do arithmetic later, it
says, even now as highly trained
MIT students who do
all kinds of much more
sophisticated math
than this, you're
still invoking that same
kind of continuous sense
of approximate number
or something like it.
OK.
All right, so where
have we gotten?
We started with this
checklist of what
number sense might mean.
And I've argued that
you adults can represent
large numerical magnitudes
without verbal counting,
that these numbers
are approximate,
and that your ability
to discriminate them
depends on the ratio,
not the difference.
And I've sort of
loosely told you
that these experiments
are generally
done unconfounded
from things like area
and that they refer to
the discrete number.
OK, what about these
other questions here?
I haven't really shown
you how abstract they are
or whether you can actually use
them in arithmetic operations.
OK, so how would we tell that?
Well, here's an experiment
that we did way back.
We did the very same
task I did on you
guys before, which has more,
except the first thing was
an array of dots.
And the second thing
was a series of tones.
OK?
Series of tones presented
faster than you could count.
Beep, beep, beep, beep,
beep, like that, right?
OK.
And so you might
think that if people
are doing some literal
perceptual thing that this
would be just like
freaking impossible, right?
But it's not.
Accuracy is just
about the same, maybe
a hair lower, but
almost the same
with the cross-modal
comparison of which has more
than with the within modality
one, visual dots to dots
or tones to tones.
This is dots to dots
and tones to tones.
And that's across.
It's a little bit surprising.
So that shows you that
whatever you're tapping into
is a pretty abstract
representation.
It's not tied to vision.
It's not tied to hearing.
And it also
completely eliminates
worries about density
or area or stuff
like that because that
doesn't work here at all.
OK?
All right.
OK, can you do
operations on these?
Sure.
Why not?
You can give people a
dot array and a dot array
and then tell them to add and
ask whether the sum of those
is greater or less than that.
Let's try it.
OK, here we go.
Everyone ready?
Consider, is the sum of this
plus this greater or less
than this.
AUDIENCE: Greater.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
OK?
And I really didn't
leave you time to count.
And so whatever you
were doing in adding,
you weren't adding
symbolic numbers.
You were adding these
approximate amounts.
OK?
Well done.
And then we could go crazy
and do it across modalities.
I'm going to ask you
to add dots to tones
and ask whether the sum is
greater or less than that.
We won't do it.
But it turns out, people
are just as good at that.
Amazing, huh?
So where has this gotten us?
This told us that whatever
this approximate number sense
that we all have,
it's damned abstract.
You can compare it across
sensory modalities pretty much
as well as within.
And you can perform
operations with it.
You can do addition.
And you can also do subtraction
just as straightforwardly.
OK?
So that's pretty cool.
But in all of these studies
and the demos with you guys,
these are done on people with
years and years of training
in arithmetic.
And so we really want to
know, are these things--
is any aspect of
this system innate?
Is it present in
very young infants?
And to what extent do
animals have these abilities?
OK?
Well, how would we find
out whether they're
present in infants?
Well, there's a bunch of ways.
But looking direction
and looking time
are the key cues you have
with newborn infants.
And so here's a study that was
done on four-day-old infants.
And what they did
was they presented--
they had a
familiarization phase.
This is done cross modally.
OK?
So they present either
sets of 12 sounds,
to, to, to, to, 12, right,
of those, or ra, ra, ra, ra,
present a bunch of
those to infants.
Or they present sets of four
taking the same total duration,
to, to.
It's just a coincidence
that it's to.
This is, I think,
done in French.
So anyway, the infants won't
be confused by the sound to.
So during that, you then show
the infants these arrays.
And you ask what
they look at more.
OK?
They're not told the task.
There's no way to
tell them a task.
It's just something they do.
And what you find is, in
the four versus 12 case
like here, that's
four versus 12,
the infants look more at
the congruent number then
the incongruent number.
OK?
So again, they're
comparing across modality.
They're hearing some
number of syllables.
And they're selectively looking
at the corresponding number
of visual forms.
No instruction.
No nothing.
Four days old.
Amazing.
OK?
So they can do that if the
comparison is four versus 12.
They can do it if
it's six versus 18.
But they kind of
can't do it very well.
I mean, it's significant,
but it's not very good
if it's four versus eight.
OK?
So they have some
sense of number.
But it's very approximate.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Did you
say they looked
at the one that
matches the number,
or they hear the sound
that goes with it?
NANCY KANWISHER: Matches.
That's congruent means match.
Looking time on congruent
versus incongruent.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that
kind of different from--
NANCY KANWISHER:
From adaptation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NANCY KANWISHER: It is.
It is totally different
from adaptation.
And herein lies a
classic annoyance
for developmental psychologists.
Because sometimes kids match.
And sometimes they
show adaptation.
And you kind of don't know.
Sometimes you don't know
which way it's going to go.
I don't know.
Heather, do we have any
insights about how you know
which way it's going to go?
Or you just try and experiment
and you find out and yeah?
Yeah.
It does mean you
have to be careful.
Because if you run
a whole experiment
on a smallish
number of infants--
and it's usually hard to
get enough because people
have to drive in
with their kids.
And this, how do you find them?
And there's other developmental
labs who have all the kids.
And it's like you're
always running experiments
with barely enough kids, right?
And so that means
there's a problem here.
Because if you would take the
result in either direction,
that's a statistical problem.
You gave yourself two
shots at it, right?
And so you have to statistically
discount your finding
because it could
have gone either way.
That is if your
prior hypothesis is
it has to go in one direction,
you're on stronger footing.
But you just suck it up
and run a few more kids.
Yeah?
OK, so good.
So this also shows that
ratio dependence, right?
They're better at it
with the big differences
than the small differences.
OK?
OK, so that's infants having
this very, very early, at least
in very crude form.
What about animals?
OK, so let's meet
Mercury the macaw.
Here's Mercury the macaw.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- To a human, the
order of the symbols
shown on the above
screen are obvious.
We have all learned from a
young age which of these symbols
represented--
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
what a good birdie.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --the lowest number
and which the highest.
However, for Mercury, the
blue-headed macaw we see here,
he has had to learn
by trial and error
the specific order to
press these symbols to get
a piece of food.
It took him quite a long time.
Mercury's brother Mars can
do a bit better than that.
He has begun to learn
the more general concept.
That is the symbols will
always have an order.
So when presented
with a new list,
he was able to rapidly
decipher the order
of new symbols, in
this case kingfisher,
warhead, hawk, hummingbird.
Pressing randomly
on the screen would
have led to him receiving the
correct answer less than 1%
of the time.
He's clearly doing
better than that.
This is interesting, as it
shows the very basic aspects
of cognition related
to numbers are
present in an animal
that is very distantly
related to humans.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
mostly, I just showed
that because it's cute.
But it's impressive ordering.
OK?
Still, he's kind of slow.
I think it only goes
up to four things.
OK, so now we're going
to meet the chimp Ayumu,
who lives in Kyoto and
who's the son of a very
famous chimp named Ai,
who was like a number wiz.
But anyway, here's Ayumu.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: I know.
I can only catch
the first three.
And then it's like I can't
even tell if he's correct,
except from the tone.
Pretty good.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Oh, got one wrong.
Anyway, mostly gets them right.
Pretty impressive, huh?
OK, so that's cool.
And order is clearly relevant.
It's part of the space.
But it's not the same as
quantity or number, right?
OK, so now we're going
to skip to the honeybee,
just for kicks because
this paper just
came out a month ago.
And I think it's awesome.
Honeybees have 1
million neurons.
And if you're impressed,
don't be impressed.
Remember like a mouse
has 100 million.
And we have 100 billion.
OK?
Six orders of magnitude.
OK, so 1 million
is like not-- no.
eight orders of magnitude.
So 1 million is not
that many, right?
OK, and further, these
guys branched off
from us, evolutionarily,
a very long time ago,
600 million years ago.
So they're tiny
little guys, not very
many neurons, totally
different kind of thing.
Who would think they have any
kind of numerical abilities?
Of course, they wouldn't, right?
Oh, and yet, they
can do arithmetic.
OK, so here's the design.
So here's what these guys
did, this wonderful lab
in Australia.
I love this stuff.
OK, so they trained
these honeybees.
This was a chamber like this.
Honeybees fly into the chamber.
And they see a number
in a color right here.
It's blue.
And it's two.
OK?
And then there's a
little entry hole.
And they can choose
to play or not play.
If they go into the
chamber, then they're
in this interior
space, where they
get to make a choice between
that pattern and that pattern.
OK?
And there's a little pole
underneath each pattern.
And if they light and
they land on the pole,
they can get some liquid.
OK?
So in the blue case, they're
rewarded over trials.
That if it's blue,
that means they
should add one to this number.
And hence, that would
be the correct answer.
And that's the incorrect answer.
OK?
That would be amazing.
Yeah?
And if they choose
the wrong number,
they get some nasty quinine.
OK?
All right, in contrast, if
the shape out front is yellow,
then they have to subtract.
So that means they have to
keep track of this number
and go in there and choose
that number minus one.
All right?
OK, so keep in mind, oh, so they
balance the total surface area.
It doesn't look
like in this figure.
But it says in the
method section they did.
I believe them.
And further, realize that
when the bee is in here,
he has to be holding that number
in memory and adding one to it
or subtracting one to it to
figure out what to choose here.
So this is pretty sophisticated.
It's not like they're
side by side, right?
OK, and yet, they're
pretty good at it.
Here's accuracy over
training trials.
By 100 trials, they're
over 80% correct.
Pretty amazing, isn't it?
OK, so then, in any good animal
or infant cognition study,
you want to show
whether it generalizes.
So then they test the same
ability with new numbers.
I forget what this range was.
But it went one to four
or something like that.
And then they go to five or six,
just to generalize the numbers,
and different shapes than were
used in the training trial.
And the accuracy
is around mid 60s.
It's not quite as good.
But it's still very good.
They're not being
reinforced here.
And they're still
doing the task.
Now, what are the
pink and blue bars?
OK, so you might think,
well, is a bee just
going to the one that
has more or less?
So instead of
learning add one, he's
learned go to the larger
number, larger than the one
that you saw at
the entry chamber,
or go to the smaller number.
But no, that's not
what they're doing.
Because the pink bars
show the performance
when both of the options are
in the same direction, right?
So the thing is blue.
So he's doing addition.
And he sees a two.
And he goes in, he has a
choice between three or four.
He can only do that if
he knows the difference
between adding one
and just taking
the thing that has more, right?
And he's well above
chance in the pink bars.
OK, so he's not
just saying, choose
the one that has more or
the one that has less.
He's adding one,
pretty accurately,
I mean sort of accurately.
Better than chance.
OK?
All right, now
that's pretty cool.
But adding one,
subtracting one, it's cool.
But do they really
have abstract concepts?
Do they understand
the concept of zero?
OK, so paper was
published last year
arguing that they have
the concept of zero.
Here's how it goes.
Same lab trains
them, in this case,
just on greater
than or less than.
So the bees are given
a choice like this.
And one set of bees is
trained on greater than
and one is trained on less than.
So this set of bees trained
on greater than chooses
this one and then this one
and then this one and so on.
OK?
Another set of bees is
trained to do the opposite.
All right?
OK, so that's the
training phase.
Then we want to test in
a generalized situation.
So now they're tested
with different shapes
and different numbers,
so threes and fours were.
Maybe threes weren't used.
I forget.
There's some numbers in here
that were not used before.
OK, so you test them
with new shapes.
And here is accuracy for
less than or greater than.
Chance is 50%.
And they're 75%.
Not bad.
OK?
So they get more
than or less than.
OK, now we want to test
the generalization.
OK, oh, yes, sorry.
This is where they changed
the range of numbers.
So the bees had not
dealt with sixes before.
So now they still have to
do greater than or less
than with a new numerical range.
And they're still
well above chance.
OK?
So then finally, they test zero.
So the bees that
have to do less than
have to say which of those
is correct, all right?
And you can see--
where did it go?
Where's the zero one?
Right here.
And they're well
above chance for both
less than and greater than.
OK?
So we could quibble
about whether that's
a concept of zero.
But the cool thing is these
bees had not been tested
with a blank card before.
And they spontaneously get the
idea that that is less than one
or two or three
or anything else.
Yeah?
So arguably, they
have a concept of zero
with no training and
only 100 million neurons.
OK, so all of that is
in trained animals.
And we can see some of
these kinds of abilities
even with untrained animals.
And I will tell you just
one more animal experiment
because it's my
all-time favorite ever
and the simplest one
in the whole set.
This was done a long time
ago by Church and Meck.
So here's what they did.
This is done in rats.
They have a training
phase, where
they train the rats
to press the two
lever if they see two light
flashes or hear two sounds.
And they press another
lever, the four lever
if they see four lights
or hear four sounds.
OK?
That's kind of basic
animal training.
It's a rodent.
They're good at this.
No big deal.
But then after the
animals have learned this,
they spontaneously throw,
in the testing phase,
a trial with two
lights and two sounds.
And the rats press the
four lever, first time.
No training.
No nothing.
Spontaneous addition.
Spontaneous abstraction
across tones and lights.
Pretty awesome, huh?
So it's not just that you
can reveal these abilities
with elaborate training.
OK, so we have all of these
different kinds of evidence
of an abstract number sense.
And they're present
in newborn infants.
And they're present in animals.
And they just seem to be part of
our basic cognitive machinery,
machinery that we
share with animals.
So how are they
implemented in the brain?
OK, so a little neuroanatomy
reminder of some basics.
This is a weird
angle of a brain.
It's kind of like this,
kind of back of the head,
front of the head,
temporal lobe,
frontal lobe around the corner.
Everybody oriented?
There is one of the longest
sulci in the brain that
starts about here.
On me, it goes like this.
And it curves around like that.
It's back here.
It goes up.
And it curves over.
OK?
It's called the
intraparietal sulcus.
And I mention that
just because it's
in a lot of the
number literature.
You saw it in the paper you
guys read for last night.
And above it is the
superior parietal lobule.
And below it is the
inferior parietal lobule.
And none of that matters other
than that a lot of the action
is in the parietal
lobe, particularly up
here around the
intraparietal sulcus.
OK?
All right, so studies
that have looked at this
includes some classical studies
of patients with brain damage
and something called acalculia.
That means loss of
ability to calculate.
OK?
And so there's two
basic kinds of acalculia
that are really
interestingly different.
So there's one
acalculic patient who
has left parietal lobe damage,
that same region I just
talked about.
And this person is
bad at approximation.
So the kinds of dot array
tasks that I gave you guys,
this guy, after brain
damage right here,
is really bad at
that kind of stuff.
And interestingly, he's
more impaired on subtraction
than multiplication.
So for example, hes worse
at, what is seven minus five
than what is seven times five?
So think about
that for a moment.
And think about what
that might mean,
especially in light of another
acalculic patient who has
a very different presentation.
He's got left temporal damage.
His approximation is fine.
So all those kind of dot array
kind of tasks and tone tasks
that I told you
about, he's good at.
This guy shows the opposite.
He's more impaired
at multiplication
than subtraction.
So do you guys have any--
oh, so first of all,
you put these two patients
together, and what do you have?
AUDIENCE: Double dissociation.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah?
What?
AUDIENCE: Double dissociation.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Double dissociation.
Right.
Two patients with opposite
patterns of deficit, right?
If we just had one, then we
could maybe tell a story.
But it wouldn't really know.
But we have two, and they
have opposite patterns.
And now that really kind of
constrains the interpretation.
David.
AUDIENCE: Can the
first person add fine?
NANCY KANWISHER: Good question.
He's not very good at adding.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
NANCY KANWISHER: Thoughts?
What do you think it means?
AUDIENCE: It might mean that
the addition and subtraction
[INAUDIBLE] use the same like--
NANCY KANWISHER: Used what?
AUDIENCE: Like they
use the same area.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
So one hypothesis is that
addition and subtraction
are just a different
beast than multiplication.
Different parts of the
brain do those things.
Totally possible.
But there's a kind of more
intuitive interpretation.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think people
tend to memorize times tables.
NANCY KANWISHER: Bingo.
Bingo.
Often, like the right
answer is something that's
like right in front of you.
Just think about, what
is it like to do that?
How do you do seven times five?
You don't think about the
meanings of the numbers.
You just blurt out 35.
Right?
It's not a very
rich number task.
I mean, it's a number task.
But it's a concrete, rote,
verbally memorized thing.
Right?
And so the idea is that those
verbalized concrete number
facts are in one domain.
One set of brain damage
would impair those.
And it's a different
thing to impair
the actual representation
of numerosity.
And the idea is
that this person is
the one with the real damage to
the approximate number system.
Right?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does that mean
that patient can be it
is a problem doing the
seven times five normally.
But when they ask for
summing seven for five times,
they're not very good.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Well, I think the
approximate number system
might have a tough time dealing
with summing seven five times.
So yeah, it has limits, right?
It can deal with it can
add two approximate things.
But you might really
lose your mind
if you tried to do a
whole string of it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If he was
working on the same digits,
like maybe seven plus
seven or seven minus seven,
expect him to maybe
do that fairly easily
if that's the case, right?
NANCY KANWISHER: Say more.
AUDIENCE: If it's a case
that his approximate--
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: He should be able
to do seven minus seven
fairly easy.
Because you know that when
you subtract the same things,
you're going to get zero.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
But it's an interesting
question, actually,
whether that would be
part of that system
or whether that's kind of
more abstract formal thing you
learn.
So I think it depends
how you do it, right?
So one of the ways--
I didn't talk about this.
But those same
experiments adding, say,
adding dots to dots, those were
also done with little kids.
And there, what you
do is you show--
I don't really
remember what it is.
But you show some
array of things,
and you hide it behind a screen.
And then you show another array
and hide it behind the screen.
And then you reveal the screen.
Like how many things are there?
That kind of stuff
works spontaneously.
So it might tap
into that system.
I think that's an
interesting question.
I'm not totally sure
how it would go.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the
second person is
bad at recall across the board?
Or is it just with numbers?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Just with numbers.
Yeah.
I mean, there's always
a little bit messy.
The patient literature is always
like some other random stuff.
And how do you account for that?
And there's lesions
in other places.
But to a first
approximation, these
are reasonably
number-specific deficits.
All right?
OK, so that's a
bit of a hint from
the neuropsychology literature.
But there's mainly
these two patients
and some other
like messier ones.
And so one wants
to use neuroimaging
to get a better picture of it.
Of course, that's been
going on for a long time.
And so here's one of the early
papers from Stan Dehaene's lab.
This is a top view of the brain.
So this is this parietal zone.
And this is what
is often referred
to as the horizontal segment
of the intraparietal sulcus.
hIPS to its friends.
And it's that sulcus I talked
about that goes up like this.
It kind of curves over.
And it's like this
bit right there.
OK?
That little orange strip.
And so what he's saying in this
review article from a long time
ago is that that region
is activated only
when you do calculation.
He means basic
arithmetic in this case.
Not when you do all
these other things.
But when this paper came
out, I'm like, yeah, right.
I don't think so.
I can't tell you how many
experiments I've run and seen
big ass activations right there
on tasks that have nothing
to do with numbers.
So looks good.
Sounded good.
He got away with it for a while.
And it's not true.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is the
reason sort of high enough
that you can zap it?
NANCY KANWISHER: Terrible.
Being filmed too.
He's a really smart, nice guy.
I just like when people are
a little bit fast and loose
and make a big claim, which
you can tell at the time
isn't quite right.
It's a little bit annoying.
Anyway.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is the region high enough
that you can zap it?
NANCY KANWISHER: Ah.
We're getting there.
Yes, indeed, you can.
But let's do a little
more basic stuff first.
OK, so the claim is
that this hIPS thing
is the locus of the
approximate number system.
That was the early claim.
OK.
And for further, the claim
implicit in this article
in this figure is
that it's involved
in numerical
representations only,
not any of these other things,
grasping tasks, manual tasks,
eye-movement tasks, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
OK, really?
And as I mentioned, like
me and lots of other people
had seen it looks like
the same regions activated
in all kinds of other
situations, especially
those involving reasoning
about spatial location.
You guys got short
shrift six weeks ago.
I meant to talk about the
parietal lobe and its role
in high-level vision.
And it just somehow
went by the boards.
But all this stuff is
involved in aspects
of vision, particularly spatial
vision, knowing what is where.
OK?
And so there's an
alternate view,
which is that there's no
specific brain region that's
specifically all only involved
in discrete number per se.
Instead, there's a common
region for processing magnitude
of almost any dimension,
whether discrete or continuous,
right, that approximate number
system or your exact number
system, and that it builds
on previous representations
of space.
OK?
For example, the
number line, right?
So you guys read this
article for last night.
And just to review
what the key point was,
this is, again, the
kind of aerial view
with the parietal lobe here.
And that's the
hIPS region, yeah,
that was in the previous slide.
And you can see it's this
horizontal part of that sulcus
way up in the parietal lobe.
And the yellow and
green means that there's
overlapping activation for both
symbolic calculation, that's
like with symbols, and for
nonsymbolic calculation.
That's like dot arrays
stuff like that, right?
And so it's activated
for both of those.
And the point of this
paper is, first of all,
that there's also overlap with
the eye-movement system, right?
And so here, they're
really asking,
is this spatial
representation kind
of co-opted in your
representation of number
using a kind of spatial
number line, right?
It makes perfect sense.
Animals need a
representation of space.
It's like extremely
basic, right?
And once you have that, you can
co-opt it and represent numbers
in that same spatial code.
And as you guys all read, the
cool result from that paper,
which is also from
Stan Dehaene's lab,
is that when you take that
region right in there,
you take those voxels in
there, and you train them
on making leftward versus
rightward saccades.
So now you have
a classifier that
looks at the pattern
of activation there,
can distinguish
a leftward versus
a rightward versus saccade.
I'm just reviewing this.
Hopefully it was clear enough.
That same classifier
can then distinguish
subtraction versus addition.
Did you guys all get
that from the paper?
Yeah?
It's pretty cool, isn't it?
Anyway, so that's
kind of nice evidence
that the same
spatial system that's
used in spatial attention
and eye movements
has been co-opted to
represent numbers as well.
OK.
All right, so I just
wanted to incorporate that.
In case anybody missed
what the paper was about,
those were the key points.
Other early studies
have asked more directly
this question of whether
different kinds of magnitude
are all represented
together in the brain.
And this study is quite clever.
They used a variant of the fact
that I showed you guys before.
Remember when saying
whether the number is
greater or less
than 65, it's harder
when it's closer to 65 than
when it's farther from 65.
OK, even though I was
showing you symbols,
that was key thing, right?
So that's called the
distance effect, right?
And that's true for
all comparisons.
And so this study exploits
that distance effect.
And they use stimuli like this.
And they ask, which
one is larger?
And it could be larger
in absolute size.
Like the two is larger here.
Or it can be larger
in number meaning
like the seven is larger.
OK, so in different
blocks, you're saying,
which one is physically larger?
Which one is numerically larger?
Which one is brighter?
That would be this one here.
And then they just have
a control with letters.
OK?
And so then-- sorry.
The design is
slightly complicated.
So there's these three main
tasks and a control task.
But then within each, they
have the difficult version
and the easy version.
And the difficult version is
when the comparisons are close,
two similar brightnesses,
two similar numbers,
two similar sizes
versus two larger ones.
OK?
So that's what all
this garbage shows.
OK, so then you do
that subtraction.
You look, and you say, OK,
what parts of the brain
are more active when you do the
difficult versus easy number
comparison?
Like saying, which is larger?
It's not that difficult.
But two versus three
versus two versus seven.
OK?
And so what they find is that
similar regions of the brain
are active for all three of
those kinds of comparisons.
OK?
So it's not like you get
just one for symbolic number
or for the two magnitude tasks.
All of those different
kinds of magnitude
activate the same regions.
And so the conclusion is that
number and size and brightness
engage a common parietal
spatial code, OK, an overlapping
region for all of these.
Does that make sense?
OK.
And so that shows, in this
case, that it's not just
symbolic number
but also magnitude.
Which one is bigger, right?
It's kind of continuous
magnitude idea.
OK?
OK.
Right.
So one worry is that,
in each of these cases,
they're comparing a difficult
condition to an easy condition.
And so maybe the
regions they got
are just engaged in any
kind of task difficulty.
Maybe if they had
done a syntactic task
on language stimuli that
was difficult versus easy,
they would get the same things.
From this experiment,
we don't know.
We'll talk more about that
in a couple weeks when
we talk about language, right?
But here's at least one control
that deals with that sort of
and which does a TMS experiment,
as you suggested a while back.
OK, so this is kind
of cool experiment.
I mean, it's weird,
but sort of cool.
OK, so what do they do?
They use-- OK, so
they have, again,
an easy task and a hard task.
Again, it's the thing
greater or less than 65.
Not very hard, right?
The hard one it's that hard.
But so is it greater
or less than 65?
And it's either a symbolic
number, or it's a dot array.
You can't really
see it, but there's
a bunch of teeny dots in there.
Or in the other
condition, they have
to say whether that ellipse is
more horizontal or vertical.
OK?
And so you spend a lot of time,
before you run the experiment,
measuring reaction time and
accuracy to balance difficulty
within the easy conditions
and balance difficulty
within the hard conditions.
OK?
So then what they do is they do
something called offline TMS.
OK?
Offline TMS, I didn't talk
about this much before.
The standard kinds of TMS,
you stick the coil right
on the subject's head.
There's a subject doing
a task on a monitor.
And somebody is standing
there holding the coil.
It's really kind of rudimentary.
And right at a key
point of the trial,
you deliver a zap to disrupt
that part of the brain.
And you find out how
much that interferes
with performance on that task.
That's the standard
online kind of TMS thing.
But there's also
offline TMS, where
you zap people at a slow
rate for like 10 minutes.
And then the idea is that
you've kind of generally
disrupted that piece of brain
for, say, another 10 minutes.
It's a little bit scarier.
But it's just like
10 minutes, right?
OK, and so that
way, you don't have
to be quite so fancy
about the precise timing.
You can just kind of
reduce its effectiveness
for a whole 10 minutes.
OK, so that's what they
did here, offline TMS.
So you sit there and get zapped
for 10 minutes slowly here.
And then you do some math tasks.
OK.
OK, so what they
find is that zapping
the left intraparietal sulcus
disrupts the magnitude tasks
on both numbers and dots.
But it doesn't mess up the
shape tasks with the ellipses,
even though the ellipses
are balanced for difficulty.
OK?
So that's at least a
little bit of an argument
that it's not just about
generic difficulty,
at least in this experiment.
OK?
All right, I think
that's what I just said.
So that's some
evidence for a role
of at least the left
intraparietal sulcus
in both symbolic and
nonsymbolic number.
Again, nonsymbolic
number just means dots
without Arabic numbers,
not just any difficulty.
All right, so that's
all very nice.
But it's crude as hell, right?
We found these big,
blurry chunks of brain
that are implicated.
And we zapped a
big chunk of brain
and slightly
reduced performance.
It's like, OK,
better than nothing.
But it's not very impressive.
What are the actual
neurons doing in the brain?
Well, now it becomes
really important and useful
that this approximate
number system
that I've been talking about
is also present in animals.
And that means we can
use animal models.
And we can record from
individual neurons
in the parietal
lobes of monkeys when
they do number tasks to find out
what actual neurons are doing.
OK?
And so there's a guy named
Andreas Nieder, who's been
doing this for a long time.
And he has some pretty
remarkable data.
And so he starts by training
monkeys to do a number task.
So here's what the monkey sees.
Monkey sees a sample,
some number of dots.
And then there's a memory
delay, in this case, one second.
And then he has to
do a matching task
and choose that
array, not this array.
OK?
So he's got to remember
that there's three dots
and choose the right three.
And notice that the sizes
and configuration of the dots
have changed.
So we have to do something
more like remember
three in whatever mental monkey
E's version of three exists.
OK?
OK, simple matching tasks.
Then he records from neurons in
the parietal and frontal cortex
in monkeys.
And he finds neurons that are
sort of specific for number.
OK, so here's time in that task.
This is the time that the
sample is presented right here.
And here is the response of
a single neuron that likes
two more than anything else.
OK?
And that too, notice,
is all different kinds
of spatial arrangements
and sizes of the dots.
What's common about all
of them is that it's two.
Next best, it likes four.
OK?
And it generalizes
across number from there.
So it's approximate.
It's not like high for two
and zero for everything else.
It's got a kind of
generalization gradient.
But it prefers two.
OK?
So that's a number neuron.
Yeah?
OK, here's a six neuron.
This neuron likes six.
Here it is same task during
presentation of trials here.
Red is six.
Next closest is like
eight and maybe 10.
So it also generalizes as well,
but it responds more to six
than anything else.
Pretty awesome.
Huh?
OK, now that doesn't tell us
how it was computed, right?
So finding a single neuron
that does something spectacular
is thrilling.
We all love it.
It's great fun.
And we're closer to
the neural circuit
because we found a neuron that
seems to be part of the action.
But notice it doesn't tell
us how that neuron made
that computation, right?
What are the circuits that
led into it, that enabled it
to be specific to six or two?
But it's still cool.
OK, but next, we want to know,
how abstract are those neurons?
This is just dot arrays.
OK?
And they're just
presented in one array.
So next, Andreas Nieder
trains his monkeys
to keep track of the number of
things that happen over time.
It's not a spatial array.
It's a temporal sequence.
OK?
So we have to see that there's
four things coming in here
and then choose the array
that matches with four.
OK?
See how this is the way to
ask how abstract those number
neurons are.
Are they really representing
the abstract magnitude of two
or six or whatever it is.
Or are they
representing something
about the shape of a two-type
array or a six-type array.
OK, and they can also test
over different modalities.
So now they present
four different tones.
And the monkey has to
choose the four dots.
OK?
Now it's both over time
and over sensory modality.
So how abstract are
those number neurons?
OK, they're pretty abstract.
So here are a few
number neurons.
Cell one is in the blue colors.
And here is its response
in light blue to dots,
one dot, two dots,
three dots, four dots.
And here is the same cell
responding to sounds.
It's specific to one, both
for sounds and dot arrays.
Isn't that cool?
And you see the green
cell is selected for two,
whether in dots or
sounds, and so forth.
Pretty cool, huh?
So these are very
abstract number neurons.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
OK, now these monkeys are
trained on number tasks.
So you might think that these
kinds of abstract number
neurons-- and they're trained
to do the generalization
from tones to arrays.
So maybe those neurons
wouldn't live in their brains
if they hadn't been
trained to do that.
But I don't have time to
show you all the data.
But in subsequent
work, the same team
has recorded from monkeys
before any training.
And you find similar
number of neurons.
So it does seem like these
are things that exist in--
and remember that's consistent
with what I said before,
which is that a lot of
these number abilities
are present in animals without
any training and in newborns.
And so it makes sense
that some of those neurons
would be around even in
advance of any training.
AUDIENCE: How many neurons
did they have to look at it
to find?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
that's a good question.
I forget what percent it is.
We could look it up
in the Nieder paper.
Yeah.
It's not like you
record from thousands,
and you find 10, right?
Remember they know where to look
from, first, the human lesion
literature and then the human
functional imaging literature.
And then there's also monkey
neuroimaging literature
where you can have
monkeys doing dot tasks.
So you can know where to look.
Because the brain's a big place.
If you're just sticking
electrodes all over,
God help you, right?
So they know to go up
in that parietal lobe
if that region is homologous
between humans and monkeys.
And there's a lot
of other evidence
that that region is homologous.
So they know how to
get in the right zone.
And I'm sure, once
in the right zone,
they're not all number neurons.
I'm sure it's a
relatively small percent.
But it's not a trivial percent.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do we have sense for
how fractions are represented?
Because all of these
seem to be discrete.
Or [INAUDIBLE], any ideas?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Well, it's tricky because,
certainly, at the single unit
level, you'd have to either
find some natural version where
monkeys think about
fractions naturally
or teach them about fractions,
which would be really hard.
Because, for some reason,
fractions are just really hard.
Like all the people who
study math education,
it's like the key problem
is, how do you get
kids to understand fractions?
I don't know why they're
such a tough thing.
But apparently, it's like
a real dividing line,
the kids who get fractions
and the kids who don't.
So I'd have to think.
But, occasionally, there
are patients with electrodes
in their brains.
And one could look at that.
Actually, I took this
slide out, but there's
a paper that came out last
year where they found number
neurons in humans as well.
I took it out because
I didn't know how
to integrate it in the lecture.
Because the number
neurons are deep
in the medial temporal lobe,
far from the parietal lobe.
And it's like, I don't
know how that fits.
I don't know if that's the
same thing or something else.
But anyway, there are at
least some number neurons
that have been found in humans.
And you could, in principle,
look for number neurons
up in the parietal lobe.
In fact, I have a guy I'm
trying to collaborate with.
I'm begging him to
collaborate with me.
He's got two people who
have arrays of electrodes
chronically implanted
right up in this region
here because they are paralyzed.
They had spinal damage.
And like Michael
Cohen's lecture,
he's got arrays of
electrodes where
he's trying to use the
neural responses there
to direct robot arms.
And so there's two
of these people
who have these chronically
implanted things.
I'm like, oh, please,
please, please,
can I collaborate with
you and get responses
from your patients' neurons?
Was there a question
over here a moment ago?
Sorry.
I thought I saw a hand go up.
OK, so let me wrap up.
So I've been arguing that
this approximate number
system is shared with
animals and newborns.
It's a pretty basic system
that lots of animals have.
It follows Weber's law,
which you should remember.
I don't like testing you
guys on esoteric facts.
But Weber's law is a
very fundamental fact.
And you should know it about
perception and, in particular,
about number.
It tells you that the ability
to discriminate two numbers
goes as the ratio, not as the
difference of those numbers.
And that these approximate
magnitude representations
measured both behaviorally and
neurally in humans and animals
are very abstract to
the particular objects,
to the modality, to
whether they come
in over space or
time, et cetera,
whether they're represented
in symbols or arrays of items.
OK?
I mentioned that there are
big individual differences
in humans in the precision of
the approximate number system.
And that is predictive of
later arithmetic abilities
independent of IQ.
And we talked about
the horizontal segment
of the intraparietal
sulcus as a key locus
for the approximate
number system in humans,
including
number-specific neurons.
And we also talked
about, both in some
of the papers I mentioned
and the paper you guys read,
that there seems to be that that
approximate number system up
here in the parietal
lobe, so far, doesn't seem
to be one of these extremely
specialized systems like faces
and motion and navigation,
which may turn out
to be less specialized later
with pending more data.
But at the moment,
we can already
see that these number
representations overlap a lot
with representations of space,
shown perhaps most dramatically
in the paper you
guys read showing
cross decoding between
eye-movement direction
and arithmetic operations.
OK, hang on.
I'm almost done summing up.
Number neurons, we
talked about that.
Yes, so we'll give the last
word to Stan Dehaene, who
started off with this
very extreme view
and has evolved to a still
interesting but slightly less
extreme view.
He says, the brain treats
number like a specific category
of knowledge requiring its
own neurological apparatus
in the parietal lobe.
But when it comes to subtler
distinctions, such as number
versus length, space, or
time, the specificity of hIPS
vanishes.
No part of hIPS
appears to be involved
in numerical computations alone.
In fact, he goes further to
say that the human brain,
in general, is neither
anisotropic white paper,
like equipotential, where all
the regions are equivalent,
nor a neat
arrangement of tightly
specialized and
well-separated modules.
All right?
Anyway, OK, there
was a question.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] just
then having this, I guess,
easier time with
approximate numbers,
given more of an
interest in that.
NANCY KANWISHER: That's a
really, really good question.
And I am sure there
are data on that.
And I don't know what they are.
But I will go look.
I always say that.
But, Dana, will you send
me an email right now to go
look up whether the
prediction from childhood
ANS to adult
arithmetic abilities
has to do with an
interest or you might
say just an emotional response.
Like if you suck at
it, it feels bad.
And you become avoidant,
and you get all
dysfunctional about it, right?
We all have-- I mean, most of us
have domains where we do that.
And math phobia is a real thing.
And who knows.
It could start in there.
So yeah, good question.
I don't know.
I will look that up.
Other questions?
OK, see you guys on Wednesday.